today's video has been made possible by
hellofresh stick around until the end to
find out more
with the second season of the witcher
just around the corner what better
excuse to take a look at the folklore
that inspired the franchise some of you
may have already picked up on the
creatures seen across the several
trailers as well as some of the other
more subtle hints as to what may be in
store today i'll be going over these
creatures giving you the basic witcher
lore without any spoilers but also
exploring the folklore behind them
one creature i was definitely excited to
see was the lesson or the leshi
in the books the leshi as they are known
in polish folklore are described as
forest spirits protectors of the
woodland
their ability to shapeshift makes them
very dangerous for anyone who
unknowingly wanders into their forest
in the game the leshen are known as
creatures that exist to kill
they can summon the surrounding wildlife
such as bears and wolves to aid them
their appearance is almost a cross
between an ant and the modern depiction
of a wendigo in the trailer for the show
we see the same terrifying figure but
with some minor changes the skull that
resembles a wendigo from the game is
gone it's a decision that some may not
agree with but in all honesty it's
probably closer in design to the
original stories and the folklore than
the game
the legend and stories of the leshi
across these slavic countries are fairly
similar the name itself roughly
translates to mean he from the forest
the leshi were spirits of the forest
that had a close association to hunting
which makes sense given that's where
much of it takes place
a leshi can alter its size at will from
enormous to tiny it can also alter its
likeness which is quite a valuable skill
for what is predominantly a trickster
spirit they have been known to kidnap
children who stumble into their woods as
well as leading travellers astray
despite this the leshi are not
necessarily considered evil spirits
their disposition towards humans is
mostly neutral it depends on the type of
person the leshi perceives you to be
if you treat the forest with respect you
will most likely be left alone however
those with bad intentions who show
disrespect to the forest may never find
their way home
there are also stories of parents
abandoning children in the forest who
they believe are cursed the leshi would
take these children in and raise them in
the forest as their own
as to what type of leshi we can expect
to see in the show personally i hope
they lean more towards the neutral
forest protector
in the trailer we have a scene with
geralt in a courtyard confrontation with
a dark-haired woman dressed in white the
woman lets out a piercing scream forcing
geralt to use quen to form a protective
barrier at first glance this appears to
be a banshee scream but later on in the
same courtyard we also see geralt
attacked by a giant bat with those two
things coupled together we can safely
assume this woman is a bruxer a type of
vampire the bruxer is a staple of the
games appearing in all of them in some
form
normally they appear as a woman with
long dark hair but they can also
shapeshift into large black bats
as we saw in the trailer their screams
are extremely powerful being able to
throw people across a room and even
pierce a witch's sign if the bruxer is
strong enough
they can manipulate a human's dreams
twisting and distorting them until they
become a nightmare they are also one of
the types of vampires in the witcher
that do not have an aversion to sunlight
interestingly enough out of all of the
various forms of vampires in the witcher
the bruxer is not rooted in slavic
folklore their stories can be found in
spain portugal and mexico and they are
sometimes referred to as brucia
the reason they are predominantly female
is because in their mortal lives they
were accused of being a witch having no
issues with sunlight they were
notoriously difficult to locate and kill
however they still prefer to roam at
night as that is when they are at their
most powerful it's rumored their powers
were given to them by satan himself
they fed mostly on the blood of men
children and small animals and much like
in the witcher they were able to
shapeshift into a variety of animals the
most common being a large bird a useful
form for scouring the lands undetected
once they found their victim they would
transform back into their female form
there are some differences between the
folklore and the witcher however the
influences are there to see
i assume what we will see in the show is
a vampire with some witch-like traits
and powers
in terms of talking points and
discussions for fans to have and
speculate over by far the best part of
this trailer is the scene in the forest
with what appears to be a witch's hut
the lights in the hut pan across the
screen like a spotlight that can see you
now this may just be an easter egg or a
teaser of something that may happen in a
following season but it does feel as if
they are teasing that we may see or at
least learn about the three crones
those who have played the witcher 3 will
be more than familiar with these three
figures as they provide some of the
creepiest and most unsettling scenes in
the game
the crones are three witches that live
in a cabin on the edge of the swamp they
are grotesque and haggard
however they can appear as young and
beautiful which they do to trick their
unsuspecting victims if you are lost in
their woods and stumble into their hut
they appear as three friendly helpful
sisters accept their hospitality and you
will end up being boiled and eaten
the child eating crohn's are heavily
inspired by the slavic legend of baba
yaga an old crone who lives in a hut
standing on chicken legs that can just
up and move at any time
baba yaga in slavic folklore is fairly
polarizing in some stories she is wicked
and not someone you want to cross pass
with
much of the time however she assumes the
role of the wise crone who is more than
willing to help adventurers who are
brave enough to seek her out
the witch's interpretation comes from
the idea that she also represents a
triple goddess the virgin the mother and
the crone the past present and future in
some tales she lives in a hut with her
two sisters also named baba yaga
the crones are a cd project red creation
they do not appear in the books so if we
do see them i'm sure their depiction
will be similar to the game
i think it's fair to assume that if we
do see them they will not be the main
antagonists of the season but i am sure
they will be up to no good
the witcher and slavic folklore in
general have a host of interesting and
terrifying monsters to draw from so
hopefully there will be a bunch we
haven't seen in any of the trailers i
did mean to make a video similar to this
for season 1 but never really got round
to it so here's a summary of some of the
creatures we saw in the first season
the kikimora is an insect monster that
lives underground and in swamps in the
books they are described as having a
spidery shape with large fangs in my
opinion the show does an okay job of
this design as in the games they are not
much more than just generic giant bugs
however in the show it has an almost
human head which is very creepy but it
may also draw some inspiration from the
original legend itself
in slavic folklore there are numerous
house spirits the domovoy is seen in a
positive light as it protects those who
inhabit the house
the kikimora is a female spirit that is
seen in a negative light essentially the
opposite of the domovoy it's thought
that she was the cause of sleep
paralysis by laying on your chest and
trying to strangle you similar to the
mara or nightmare of scandinavian
folklore there are also kikimora who
inhabit the swamps and bogs but they
don't have the same spider-like
appearance as they do in the witcher
they are small elderly women with
hunchbacks and pointed noses who use
moss and grass as clothing they hide by
roadsides and riverbeds kidnapping
children and knocking passersby into the
water and drowning them not exactly the
most friendly babushkas
in episode 3 we saw the appearance of a
striga a woman who has been transformed
into a monster by a curse
she is unable to control her emotions
filled with anger and hatred they lash
out and devour any living beings in
their path
the strigas do share some elements with
the romanian vampires known as the
strigoi however they are based on the
polish legend of the striga a female
demon similar to a vampire that needs to
feed on human flesh
a female demon similar to a vampire that
needs to feed on human flesh it's
believed they are born with two hearts
and two souls they even had two sets of
teeth the superstitions even went as far
to say that babies who were born with a
slightly developed teeth must have been
strigger
if the striga were killed one soul would
pass on and the remaining soul would
bring them back to life meaning they
would have to be put down twice
some other creatures we saw worthy of a
mention include the doppler the nekkers
the sylvan and the gin
hopefully we see more creatures in
season two as i really do enjoy the
witcher and slavic folklore in general
let me know which of these creatures or
characters you're most excited to see
as we mentioned earlier today's video
has been sponsored by hallo fresh
buying your own ingredients and
preparing your own meals is great but
for many with a busy schedule it's hard
to do with hellofresh you can have a
meal kit that includes fresh ingredients
and cooking instructions sent directly
to your door simply follow the
instructions provided and you have
access to all sorts of tasty meals
within half an hour each week there is a
selection of new recipes to choose from
with low carb low-fat and vegetarian
options the mill kits are sent in almost
entirely recyclable packaging so you can
even reduce your carbon footprint
i've been trying hello fresh for a few
months now and i've been extremely happy
with what i've received and the amount
of time i've been able to save some of
my favorite meals were the teriyaki
chicken and rice the honey roasted duck
with mashed potatoes and for anyone who
loves pasta dishes there are dozens to
choose from
the meals look and taste great you also
don't have to be a master chef to make
them
if you would like to try hello fresh for
yourself then go to hellofresh.com
and use code mythology 14 for up to 14
free meals and 3 free gifts
so give it a try and let me know which
meals are your favorite
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
you